[Musique]
cela prend exactement 38 ceux des lignes
pour voir tout paris c'est le temps dont
a besoin un ascenseur pour atteindre le
59e étage de la tour montparnasse la
métropole j au pied de la plus haute
maison de paris à une hauteur de 209 m
elle s'étale jusqu'à l'horizon un océan
de maison qui n'en finit plus la
destination rêvée pour les touristes
censée être la ville de l'amour de
laventure du romantisme et des lumières
paris la ville des miracles quand on
voit le sacré coeur c'est basilique
blanche sur la colline de montmartre on
y croit facilement au miracle de paris
c'est lui qui se sent perdu ici
reconnaîtra la coupole dorée du dôme des
invalides
le voilà le célèbre arc de triomphe
et bien évidemment la tour eiffel on la
connaissait depuis longtemps bien avant
qu'on vienne la première fois et chacun
a déjà entendu parler de la place de la
concorde
voilà mais maintenant les faits la
capitale française s'étend sur 105
kilomètres carrés plus de deux millions
de personnes vivent dans ces murs homme
si on y rajoute ceux qui habitent aux
alentours on arrive à presque 10
millions de personnes avec la grande
banlieue
le molosse paris se divise en vingt
arrondissements chaque circonscription
est constitué de quatre quartiers
parisiens le véritable centre c'est
l'île de la cité
une île sur la scène l'origine de paris
sur cette île se dresse un des plus
grands monuments parisiens la cathédrale
de notre dame
il n'y a plus de 100 musées à paris au
musée d'histoire on peut observer
l'évolution de la ville les parisii un
peuple de chasseurs de pêcheurs et de
marins se sont installées environ 250
ans avant jésus-christ sur l'île de la
cité
à cette époque lille ça plaît lui tué 2
6 1 n'ont que les parisiens avaient
repris les anciens habitants celtic qui
peuplaient lille
auparavant les conquérants romain
appelèrent l'endroit lutèce et ils
l'agrandir au delà de l'île à droite et
à gauche du fleuve en lans 51 avant
jésus-christ lutèce fut une colonie
romaine pendant 300 ans la ville prit le
nom de paris au ivème siècle après
jésus-christ lille sur le fleuve sur
laquelle l'histoire de la ville comment
ce ne fut pas pour parer uniquement
importante de part de sa position
géographique les parisiens et les
romains se réfugièrent sur l'île de la
cité lorsqu'ils furent attaqués par les
uns et les francs
on dit que les prières arden de
sainte-geneviève empêchèrent attila de
détruire la ville
et c'est ainsi qu'elle est devenue la
patronne s de paris le roi franc clovis
s'installa sur l'île en 508 avant
jésus-christ et filles de paris la
capitale l'île de la cité tel un
vaisseau a toujours subi les remous du
temps un vaisseau qui décorent les
armoiries de la ville
leur devise est typique fluctuat nec
mergitur il flotte mais ne coule pas on
peut admirer l'île de la scène sur de
nombreuses cartes postales ainsi que son
monument le plus connu notre dame
il n'y a aucune ville de la cathédrale
qui n'ait déjà été admirée dans les
endroits les plus reculés du monde pour
les touristes la visite du dôme de paris
est un must et souvent le commencement
de toutes les visites guidées la
cathédrale
son nom officiel notre dame de paris
elle a aussi les surnoms la paroisse
historique l'église mère de la nation ou
le temple de l'histoire de france
ce chef-d'oeuvre gothique avec ses
clochers de 69 mètres de haut est
construit là où les celtes rendait des
sacrifices aux dieux sur un temple la
construction de notre dame commencera au
milieu du 12e siècle et fut achevé deux
cents ans plus tard on entre dans
l'église par trois portails
au milieu le portail du jugement dernier
notre dame et le centre de la france
devant le portail c'est le point zéro à
partir duquel toutes les rues du pays
vont être calculé on dit que celui qui
foulent du pied ce point zéro y
reviendra
les particularités architecturales de
cette basilique à cinq vaisseaux et
transept ferait l'objet d'un film en soi
c'est pourquoi nous décrirons ici
l'esprit de ce sanctuaire national avec
ses nombreuses chapelles ses audacieuses
poutrelles en ogive ces merveilleuses
rosas on voit ici pour la première fois
des particularités architecturales qui
seront dominante dans l'architecturé
française jusqu'au 19ème siècle le
mariage de la monumentalité et de
l'élégance l' équilibre des proportions
associé à une mise en forme d'harmonie
presque classique même la révolution n'y
peut rien changer
elle qui fit de la maison de dieu un
temple de la raison après avoir volé ses
trésors et détruit ses statuts plus tard
elle fut un entrepôt de 20 mais notre
dame survécu les nombreux visiteurs qui
chaque jour ce prêt jusqu'à sa plate
forme ni sentent que peu l'esprit de
l'histoire plus personne ne craint
aujourd'hui la vue de ces chimères de
pierre on tremble plus tôt au souvenir
du sonneur de notre dame
victor hugo qui immortalisa le célèbre
sonneurs quasimodo et la tzigane
esmeralda ad pas la signification de
notre dame et de l'île de la cité très
justement dans son roman
près de la cathédrale se dresse l'une
des plus importants de construction de
lignes le palais de justice
des centaines d'années durant le centre
du pouvoir
les celtes parisy et résidèrent déjà
dans de simples habitation puis et
romain et les francs avant que les rois
français ni construisent le palais plus
tard les prisonniers y furent conduits
par les tribunaux et emmenés sur des
charrettes à grandes roues à la
guillotine
parmi ces prisonniers la reine marie
antoinette et le révolutionnaire
robespierre aujourd'hui ce bâtiment
porte un nom qui décrit bien sa fonction
le palais de justice
pratiquement encastrée dans les dédales
du palais de justice a survécu un
chef-d'oeuvre gothique de grande qualité
la sainte chapelle
elle est considérée comme l'une des plus
belles constructions parisienne
la sainte chapelle se compose de deux
chapelles l'inférieur lieu de recueil
pour les courtisans et le peuple et la
supérieure avec ses vitraux incomparable
qui était uniquement réservée à la
famille royale
les fenêtre d'une hauteur de 15 mètres
ont été construites en même temps que
l'église entre 1245 et 1248 ce sont les
plus vieilles fenêtres de paris les murs
luminescents ne semble pas respecter les
lois de la gravité
car la construction n'est porté que par
de fines poutrelles plus de 1100 scène
dont la moitié encore sont d'origine
nous relate des récits bibliques
il paraît qu'on gardera encore de nos
jours dans la chapelle du château les
restes de la couronne de ronces du
christ et des instruments du martyre de
jésus la sainte-chapelle sorti intact de
l'incendié du fort royal au xviiie
siècle
l'île de la cité coeur de paris ne
serait présenté qu'insuffisamment si
l'on ne parle pas des ponts avec
lesquels l'urbanisme moderne commence à
le pont neuf
aujourd'hui comme lors de sa
construction sous henri iv en 1605
il protège les exclus sociaux et sert de
point de rendez vous aux amoureux
une promenade pour tous ceux qui veulent
jeter un regard de ce côté de la scène
du haut de ce monument on l'appelle à le
pont neuf parce que ce fut le premier
pont sur lequel on ne construit pas de
maison la vue imprenable sur l'île de la
cité en fit le pont le plus aimé de
paris et voici à quoi ressemblaient les
autres ponts à l'époque des maisons à
étage occupent chaque centimètre carré
des espaces la densité n'empêche pas les
citoyens de s'amuser à des jeux en
bateau le pont neuf
une partie d'un des paysages urbains les
plus célèbres du monde chanté par
jacques verrière et nathalie gérault
[Musique]
au printemps sur les toits déchire on
est tous les fruits qu'au caire avec le
premier rendez vous à cela
car le vent en direct à paris n'a plus
qu'un seul souci cette année musarder
dans tous les cas si la feuille ils ont
censuré c'est regardons le chemin
si paris
[Musique]
je
ban
vous
[Musique]
on appâte à paris on attend monde entier
mais maintenant qu'il l'a battu par
[Musique]
avion dans ce sens avait depuis paris
oui la scène on dit que c'est qu'est
réunissent les amoureux du monde entier
cependant la ville est séparé en deux la
rive gauche qui depuis la construction
de l'université et du monastère est
considérée comme la rive des
intellectuels à nouveau m et comme celle
des révoltes en 1968 les manifestations
étudiantes commencèrent place saint
michel
là où se trouve la fontaine saint michel
construite en 1860 par davioud et décoré
par les sculptures de durée
on peut commencer sa découverte de paris
par ici quand on est nouvel arrivant
dans les rues et les ruelles
pittoresques sur lesquels planent depuis
longtemps une odeur de pizzas et de
couscous
on se sauve alors vite vers les quais de
la seine vers les stands des
bouquinistes
auparavant les étudiants et acheter
leurs livres leurs bouquins de la via le
nom aujourd'hui on trouve surtout des
amateurs de vieux graphique de plan
historique et de livres d'antiquités qui
veulent faire des affaires
au quartier latin le quartier des
étudiants il y a la plus grande
université française la sorbonne en 1254
robert de sorbonne fondis un collège qui
fut repris environ 400 ans plus tard par
le cardinal richelieu depuis 1821
on trouve dans le gigantesque complexe
les directions universitaire
dans ce quartier animé il y a aussi des
plages de calme comme la place
furstenberg le peintre delacroix avait
déjà admirer sa beauté c'est là que se
trouvait son atelier de la croix un des
grands hommes français les plus grands
d'entre eux sont enterrés au panthéon un
mausolée nationale qui était à l'origine
une église
ils sont tous réunis la voltaire
rousseau victor hugo zola et plus de 50
autres personnalités encore à proximité
du panthéon dans le jardin du luxembourg
un parc baroque
nous considérons aujourd'hui que les
boulevards du quartier sont typiques de
paris on y fait du shopping
les cafés les bistrots et des stands
sont alignés côte à côte mais personne
ne pense qu'au temps de napoléon iii son
préfet le baron rossmann restructura
radicalement la ville on rase à vingt
mille maisons on en reconstruisit 40000
les rues droite était bonne pour les
défilés militaires mais elles
détruisirent les constructions de jadis
cependant la vie parisienne se manifeste
encore sur les boulevards laisser faire
laisser aller même à l'ombre de l'église
de saint-germain-des-prés
on ne sent pas le pouls de la grande
ville dans les petites rues derrière
l'église des vieilles boutiques des
petits cafés au bord de la rue des
légumes du poisson sans l'odeur du fast
food et du couscous
ça c'est la rue debussy avec ses petites
rues adjacentes
une idylle et qui le reste le quartier
latin le boulevard saint germain le
boulevard saint michel des endroits et
des noms qui rendent aussi un peu triste
où sont ils passés mais chansonnier et
les poètes les bohémiens la technique
les remplacent aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je pense que
vous
non
[Musique]
la rive gauche n'est pas seulement un
lieu pour les visiteurs à la recherche
du temps perdu au quartier latin
là où les trains partaient et arrivaient
de province à la gare d'orsay se trouve
aujourd'hui un musée renommé où est
rassemblée la plus grande collection de
tableaux impressionnistes
la gare fut construite en 1900 en face
du louvre comme pièces décoratives pour
l'exposition universelle la gare qui
malgré son apparence élégante devaient
être rasées dans les années 60 une des
inaugurations de musées les plus
réussies eu lieu entre 1978 et 1986
l'architecte milanais à roanne qui
créera cadre hors du commun pour les
collections surtout pour les collections
de peintres français d'art déco et les
impressionnistes mais les sculptures ici
une de rodin aussi rendu le musée
d'orsay célèbre cette culture une petite
danseuse de 14 ans et d'edgar degas un
des rares impressionniste qui travailla
aussi en tant que sculpteur
de même le déjeuner sur l'herbe
d'edouard manet tableau qui fit scandale
au salon de 1863
elle devint le manifeste d'un groupe de
peintres qui cherchait à fixer l'instant
parent a représenté dans le bal de la
moule un galet la joie de vivre du
peuple parisien
l'ambiance de montmartre en peinture
voir renoir mais aussi voir si cela est
toulouse lautrec cézanne et bien
d'autres encore tout cela rend un séjour
à paris si précieux de plus on trouve
rive gauche un monument d'un style
particulier celui qui dit on est le plus
beau monument religieux de france qu'ils
étaient construits depuis la renaissance
le dôme des invalides
sous la coupole de 105 mètres de haut
repose le français le plus célèbre et
peut-être même le plus représentatif
napoléon
le dôme des invalides pris sa forme
actuelle au xviie siècle sous louis xiv
une maison pour soldats retraités aux
malades étaient déjà en place en 1604 le
cercueil de napoléon cercueil de
porphyre phalanx des rouges
dans son exil de sainte hélène le monde
avait radicalement changé même sa vie le
pari avait un nouveau visage l'école
militaire par contre avaient déjà été
instituée par louis xiv le bâtiment
d'époque classique une école militaire
pour officier a été construit sous
l'initiative de la maîtresse du roi
madame de pompadour elle elle va ainsi
un monument à la gloire de ses
protecteurs
en face de l'école militaire en
direction de la seine se trouve le champ
d'exercice un chant qui porte en
l'occurrence le nom du dieu de la guerre
mars le champ de mars
aujourd'hui transformé en parc relie
l'école militaire et la tour eiffel
avant de nous consacrer à la
construction de faire de monsieur fl
regardons de l'autre côté de la seine
exactement dans laxe de l'école
militaire on trouve la tour eiffel le
palais de chaillot avec ses musées à
l'avant de la place du trocadéro
toujours très visitée par les touristes
on a une vue d'ensemble imprenable
gustave eiffel a créé la véritable image
de marque de paris avec sa construction
de faire de 300 mètres de haut
l'esthétique technique de cette oeuvre
réalisée en 1889 pour l'exposition
universelle a trouvé deux sont en plus
d'opposants que de partisans
à cette époque on préférait le parc des
expositions un grand hangar de verre et
de fer auquel on accédait en passant par
la porte de la tour eiffel ce hangar
n'existe plus depuis longtemps
à sa place on a aménagé le champ de mars
la tour eiffel elle a survécu et avec
elle la plus belle vue de paris
[Musique]
tournons nous maintenant vers l'autre
paris le paris bourgeois les quartiers
royaux le pari du gouvernement
le louvre les champs elysées mais aussi
montmartre en un mot la rive droite la
rive droite et ses arrondissements
mais par où commencer par la tour
saint-jacques peut-être ce clocher se
dresse juste derrière l'île de la cité
l'église elle même fut rasée en 1802 les
chimères et les figures sainte ne
peuvent pas faire concurrence à celle de
la cathédrale
mais elle protège pour ainsi dire la
place du châtelet
jusqu'à la révolution il y avait ici une
forteresse dont on contrôlait les ponts
qui menait jusqu'à l'île de la cité
ici se trouve aussi deux grands théâtres
parisiens face à face
construit par davioud que nous avons
déjà mentionné comme architecte de la
fontaine saint michel
à quelques pas de là le parvis de
l'hôtel de ville
la ville y est administrée depuis 1356
la construction médiévale puis remplacé
par un palais renaissance dans le style
des châteaux de la loire
c'est un ce bureau que le maire de paris
décide du destin de la ville
si l'on prend part aux réceptions
officielles on peut se laisser
impressionner par l'intérieur pompeux de
l'hôtel de ville
jusqu'en 1830 les exécutions publiques
se faisait sur ce parvis le mot hôtels
se retrouve aussi dans l'expression
hôtel particulier un terme utilisé pour
dénommer les palaces de la noblesse
parisienne on en trouve beaucoup dans le
quartier du marais entre l'hôtel de
ville et la bastille un grand nombre de
ses hôtels particuliers sont restaurés
quelques hôtels musées comme par exemple
ici l'hôtel carnavalet qui est aussi le
musée de la ville de paris
ces hôtels ont presque tous une cour
intérieure avec un jardin privatif
séparer de la rue par de hautes
murailles
le vieux balai a été construit par
l'architecte françois mansart au xviie
siècle dans les 80 salles on peut y
visiter de nos jours une exposition sur
l'histoire de paris avec des peintures
des sculptures et des reliques des
siècles passés
une place d'honneur est réservé à la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen document datant de 1789
un an plus tard on fêtait pour la
première fois le 14 juillet en
commémoration de la prise de la bastille
charti y en a immortalisé l'instant dans
une fresque magistrale les citoyens et
des soldats s'y embrassent on peut
reconstruire l'histoire de paris à
travers ses tableaux une leçon
d'histoire par excellence au fait
l'hôtel carnavalet était un lieu de
rencontre pour intellectuels qui
entretenait des causeries mondaine c'est
ainsi que la très fine madame de sévigné
qui participa activement à une critique
de l'actualité mondaine nous offrit sa
vision de paris
l'hôtel salé construits avec l'argent
des impôts prélevés sur le commerce du
sel a aussi été restaurée et accueille
dans ses murs la plus grande collection
d'oeuvres de pablo picasso ce génie
incontesté du 20e siècle
ici encore on retrouve la même
disposition architectural celle d'un
petit château telle qu'elle fut en vogue
jusqu'au xviiie siècle après plusieurs
séjours dans la capitale picasso
s'installa à paris en 1904 voilà un
autoportrait datant de 1901
voilà comment ils se voyaient lors de
son arrivée à montmartre et voilà
comment le photographe le voyait au même
instant
l'atelier de picasso était toujours
remplie d'amis et de collègues peintre
voici la russe olga khokhlova sa
troisième muse une oeuvre de 1917
après sa période cubiste picasso
retourna à la peinture figurative et
voici encore un portrait d'olga on voit
bien la progression qu'a suivi l'artiste
jusqu'en 1929 époque où il n'a pas ce
tableau à l'hôtel salé on peut suivre
toutes les époques stylistique de
picasso ce portrait vient de la période
bleue
il fut encore pas à barcelone les deux
frères de 1906 de la période rose puis
les influences du cubisme sacré coeur
paul habillé en arlequin de 1924 plus
tard picasso a pas néo classique pour
s'adonner de plus en plus à ces
productions expressive et déformante au
musée on peut voir aussi ses sculptures
originales
paris a toujours été une ville de
contrastes des hôtels particuliers à
côté de petites maisons bourgeoises
osman a changé la ville de façon
radicale contre l'air du temps
aujourd'hui encore on critique les
nouvelles constructions par exemple le
centre pompidou les architecteurs
richard rogers et renzo piano ont laissé
courir tous les tuyaux d'alimentation à
l'extérieur de l'édifice
certains disent même que beaubourg
ressemble plus à une usine qui a amusé
d'autres d'avis contraire considèrent
que c'est une expression contemporaine
idéal en tout cas paris a encore montré
ce que voulait dire innover et presque
10 millions de touristes par an lui en
rendent hommage
les collections d'art et les expositions
itinérantes ils sont aujourd'hui
acceptée en le complexe futuriste la
fontaine stravinsky de niki de saint
phalle et de jean tinguely a presque
l'air anodine
ici tous les touristes valent à appuyer
sur le bouton
aujourd'hui les loyers grimpent dans ce
quartier de manière astronomique mais
c'était auparavant un quartier pauvre un
quartier à assainir selon les urbanistes
le ventre de paris
c'est là que les marchands avaient leur
mot à dire dans le café au pied de
cochon qui se trouvait en face des
halles on pouvait manger la meilleure
soupe à l'oignon de la ville 24 heures
sur 24 les halles était tout comme la
tour eiffel typiquement parisienne la
forme ronde des halles est resté
symboliquement
quand les halles de vars trop petit pour
l'énorme marché du plein centre ville on
les déplace à en banlieue parisienne
l'art et l'urbanisme moderne ont refoulé
tout un peuple bigarrée de marchands de
bonne de souteneurs de clochards et bien
d'autres encore devant l'église
saint-eustache le quartier soit disant
mal famés devint un quartier chic
le forum des halles fait aussi partie du
ventre de paris
un énorme centre commercial surgi de
nulle part trois cent mille personnes
s'y ruent chaque jour on y trouve
restaurants cinémas discothèques à fait
et manèges les façades des rares maisons
que la grande restructuration à épargner
se reflète dans les bâtiments de verre
[Musique]
le nouvel opéra de paris place de la
bastille et moderne et bien dans
l'esprit du siècle
[Musique]
au centre du sens giratoire le génie de
la victoire appelez la colonne de
juillet en allemagne
elle a été construite à la mémoire des
victimes de la révolution de juillet
[Musique]
c'est l'endroit où se trouvait jusqu'en
1789 la bastille une prison lugubre est
terrible et qui le restera jusqu'au jour
où le peuple assailli la bastille
transformer en bastion de défense des
forces de paris à 14 juillet aujourd'hui
fête nationale le symbole de
l'oppression
tout commença au matin du 14 juillet
1789 quand les citoyens de paris
s'emparèrent des armes au dôme des
invalides et marchèrent sur la bastille
ils attaquèrent comme un seul homme
rapidement les soldats de la bastille
issers le drapeau blanc
quelques jours plus tard les murs du
bâtiment détester furent détruits la
prise de la bastille marqua le début de
la révolution française
le roi et la reine furent destitué on
voit ici le roi louis saez et marie
antoinette se faire leurs adieux en
prison en larmes
surveillé par le gardien de prison
rochet louis saez est mort le 21 janvier
1793 place de la concorde guillotiné la
même année en octobre marie antoinette
subissait le même sort les temps
changent r même pour le palais royal
le palais du louvre qui aujourd'hui
abrite une institution démocratique
le conseil d'état le louvre le château
des rois de france
on ne peut réellement apprécié sa
dimension que dans une perspective
aérienne le louvre n'a pas toujours eu
l'apparence qu'il a aujourd'hui
l'histoire de sa construction commence
au 12e siècle et elle est très complexe
plus que par son histoire les visiteurs
sont intéressés par la plus grande
collection d'oeuvres d'art du monde qui
recouvre différentes périodes
artistiques occidentale de l'antiquité à
nos jours
voici la vénus de milo un modèle pour
bien des sculpteurs de l'antiquité
la section égyptienne est renommé elle
est présentée sur plusieurs des 200
salles les large galerie du louvre sont
réservés à la peinture
les objets d'art du moyen âge et de la
renaissance sont incontournables
comptez le nombre d'oeuvres majeures qui
sont ici exposés impossible même si la
mona lisa de léonard de vinci ne doit
pas manquer à l'appel
des peintres français et italiens
flamand espagnol et allemand sont
représentés voici un célèbre
autoportrait de dürer et bien évidemment
peter paul rubens un des porte-paroles
du style baroque l'infante de velazquez
et chaque génération et de nouveaux
fasciné par le peintre hollandais
rembrandt
les salles sont aussi plein de paysages
de différentes époques
ici un paysage modèle de claude lorrain
ici une vue de venise par canaletto les
maîtres du classicisme sont présents
tels que l'indre avec ses nus parfait
eugène delacroix éternise à l'image
nationale des français dans son tableau
la liberté conduite par le peuple
l'ancien côtoie le 9 mai louvre on
attend la cour intérieure en passant par
une pyramide de verre mais critiquent la
décrivent comme une serre qui détruit
l'harmonie de la façade
ceux qui sont pour parle du monument le
plus osé et le plus beau de paris mais
les contradictions et les controverses
font partie de paris tout comme la
pyramide du louvre
en face du louvre après le petit arc de
triomphe se trouve le jardin des
tuileries la place de la concorde avec
l'obélisque puis l'arc de triomphe et
enfin la nouvelle arche du quartier de
la défense
cela représente un axe d'environ 10 km à
travers paris chaque point que nous
avons mentionné sur cette diagonale
mérite d'être visité le jardin des
tuileries par exemple le parc fut
aménagée en 1664 et est un départ que
les plus prisés de paris avec ses allées
rêveuse ses statuts de maillots ses bons
essais kiosque
[Musique]
à l'entrée du jardin des tuileries la
place de la concorde
toujours très animées c'est la plus
grande roue tourne du monde qui fait 400
sur 200 m qui était et qui est toujours
la plus grande scène parisienne
mais les pièces qu'on joie ici furent
variés comme le nom même de la place à
l'origine à la gloire du roi la place
devait offrir un cadre digne de recevoir
une effigie du roi à cheval puis pendant
les treize mois de la révolution ont
guillotine a ici plus de 2500 tête
enfin on y dresse à l'obélisque un
cadeau d'égypte au roi citoyen louis
philippe
au fait on trouve aussi ici le jeu de
paume
un musée qui auparavant exposait les
tableaux des impressionnistes
aujourd'hui c'est un musée d'art
contemporain napoléon rebaptisa ce
théâtre de plein air en place de la
concorde
de nos jours on y joue la pièce les
temps modernes la place de la concorde
est un centre névralgique de la
circulation parisienne et des flots de
voitures s'y pressent en direction de
l'arc de triomphe au nord de la place se
trouve l'ancien opéra de paris le palais
garnier le temple culturel de la
bourgeoisie parisienne le symbole du
second empire tout à fait dans le style
de napoléon iii
un architecte jusque là inconnu charles
garnier s'imposa contre une concurrence
de 170 projets la construction commença
en 1862 ont pris en considération les
exigences pompeuse de la classe
dominante et les besoins les plus
modernes du théâtre de l'époque le faste
atteint son sommet dans le foyer doré de
nos jours l'opéra n'est plus
techniquement à la hauteur c'est
pourquoi on a construit le nouvel opéra
de la bastille ce bâtiment est
maintenant réservée aux ballets
haussmann raza tout un quartier pour la
construction de cet opéra le boulevard
du même nom derrière l'opéra le rappelle
à nos mémoires
sur ce boulevard se trouve le grand
magasin le plus célèbre de paris les
galeries lafayette tous les désirs
s'accomplit sous sa coupole magistral
les parfums le chic et accessoires de la
vie parisienne
si on ne veut rien dépenser on peut
quand même se régaler les yeux à peu de
frais c'est un plaisir d'assister à la
rénovation de notre-dame à l'aube du
xxème siècle pourtant les habitués du
grand magasin se fournissent ici emploi
gratuit offert par les galeries
lafayette mais beaucoup d'entre eux ne
sert pas le cordon de la bourse
après tout paris est la ville de la mode
les grands couturiers dans les palais se
trouve rue de rivoli et rue du faubourg
saint-honoré ne se gêne pas pour
présenter à intervalles réguliers leurs
collections dans ce magasin
[Musique]
à part faire se déplacer
chan
[Musique]
nadine est un footix
ans
la toile
changement de plateau mais il sans
quitter les quartiers de la rive droite
nous avons escaladé la montagne de paris
au montmartre
enfin juste une colline mais qui semble
dominer paris d'un blanc éclatant on
dira qu'elle est couronnée par la
basilique du sacré-coeur
les architectes les plus renommés ont
refusé son style ou bonbons on dit que
c'est un mélange improbable de style
romain byzantin et classique
les touristes eux sont emballés par sa
beauté et par son exposition
exceptionnelle
les amateurs d'art refuse bien entendu
de se mêler aux touristes qui se
pressent place du tertre
plutôt que de prendre des photos on s'y
fait dessiner la petite place est
toujours très visité elle profite de la
renommée des artistes qui avaient
auparavant leur atelier sur la butte de
paris montmartre
jadis un chemin qui était difficile à
gravir ce n'est pas étonnant que les
loyers étaient bon marché qui avait t-il
ici hormis l'église ce que les artistes
rouvert à l'époque abordable d'autres le
trouvère chic les cafés ou lan pays avec
ses tableaux sont devenus des
attrape-nigauds mais même de nos jours
on ne peut échapper à quelques pas de là
au charme bucolique de cette colline
et même ici on en vient à parler du
grand art ceux qui sont à la recherche
d'oeuvres de salvador dali y visiteront
le musée espace tally oeuvres plastiques
et graphiques de sept espagnols
excentrique
ils sont représentés
jeune homme
je
non
et puis dans le cimetière montmartre on
y trouve encore la tombe d'emile zola
ces ossements ont été emmenés en 1908
dans la nécropole où reposent les grands
hommes français au panthéon
d'autres personnalités y reposent aussi
de gars le poète heinrich heine stendhal
sacha guitry et truffaut c'est plein de
chat
la nuit tous les chats sont gris ici
aussi mais pas tous les chats qui traîne
à montmartre comme entre la place clichy
et pigalle
un quartier qui vit de la belle époque
mais qui pourtant n'est qu'un piège à
touristes
mais si l'on veut absolument vivre le
vice à paris et bien voilà on en suit
les traces ici mètre par mètre
pourtant même ici on devrait éviter de
généraliser l'art du showbiz d excellent
programme et des dîners aux chandelles
l'art des shows télévisés et des
prestations internationales
on le trouve aussi ici le paradis la
terre
au fait ce n'est pas infi galles et
c'est tant mieux
des extraits du programme entre chansons
revues et kankan
[Musique]
à
ward
[Musique]
non
la nuit n'appartient pas qu'aux revue
conduire de nuit sur les champs elysées
c'est une aventure nocturne
le spectacle permanent coffre paris ce
spectacle des temps modernes s'offre à
nos yeux jour et nuit les champs elysées
avec ses dix voix ne sont pas absolument
représentatif du bon temps le bon temps
c'était avant on l'appelait la belle
époque
cette fin de siècle au prix à paris
entre autres un édifice qui mit en scène
lax champs elysées dôme des invalides de
manière efficace
le grand palais construit en 1900 pour
l'exposition universelle
couronné d'un kadrige de bronze fait
partie de cette mise en scène le grand
palais et ses 5000 m² d'exposition est
un des plus grands centres d'exposition
de la ville
juste en face se trouve le petit palais
on accueille ici les collections
parisiennes et des expositions
itinérantes
les deux bâtiments furent construites en
même temps mais tandis que le petit
palais est encore d'un style baroque
le grand palais cache derrière sa façade
une structure de fer et de verre les
deux palais et le pont alexandre iii
forme d'un ensemble
le pont avec sa pierre de taille ces
candélabres de bronze et ses
ferronneries surplombe la scène dans un
arc d'une longueur de 100 m nombreux
sont ceux qui pensent que ce joyau de la
belle époque est le plus beau pont de
paris
c'est un témoignage de l'alliance signée
en 1892 entre la france et l' empire
russe saristes le tsar nicolas ii et le
président français déposèrent ensemble
la première pierre
le président de la république qui
résidaient comme tous ses successeurs à
l'elysée la relève de la garde du matin
s'effectue rue saint-honoré cette rue
qui d'autre part est synonyme de haute
couture
la république française et démocratique
mais même les présidents républicains
ont toujours su se dorer au soleil du
prestige de la splendeur de paris et
quand l'occasion se présente il se
montre et se fait aux champs elysées que
ce soit pendant des parades des jours
fériés ou des réceptions officielles
cette avenue magistral souvent appelée
la plus belle avenue du monde n'était de
la fin du xviiie siècle qu'un chemin
pour sortir de la ville on trouve
aujourd'hui à paris des rues bien plus
belles qui ont été modernisées et
commercialisé mais aucune n'est aussi
représentative aussi à cause de l'arc de
triomphe
napoléon le fit construire en l'honneur
de la grande armée française après les
victoires de marengo et d'austerlitz cet
arc 2 50 m de haut et 2 45 m de large
qui avait été prévu pour la place de la
bastille pu terminer sous louis philippe
en 1836 la marseillaise de la célèbre
c'est une des quatre grandes sculptures
latéral
tout en haut de l'arc de triomphe se
trouve un petit musée mais on grimpe les
marches pour pouvoir apprécier d'en haut
une vue fantastique 12 grandes avenues
parts de l'arc en forme des toiles
silence huile axe est ouest qui part du
louvre passe sur la place de la concorde
et l'arc de triomphe et qu'on aille un
peu plus à l'ouest
on y discerne au loin les quartiers de
nanterre et de la défense c'est là que
s'est exprimé le paris du 20è siècle à
partir de 1956 lorsque la guerre
d'indochine fut terminée on assiste à un
développement économique et à un
élargissement de la ville dans la région
parisienne
la défense a été construite pour
accueillir des bureaux et des
administrations
l'arche s'y trouvent depuis 1989 est
devenu le symbole de ce quartier
éprouvette provoquant de nouveau des
controverses
elle nous montre sans aucun doute la
route de l'avenir
au nord de la ville à la porte de la
villette on a aussi mis un accent
futuriste aux et une architecture
insolente et urbaine un parc des
sciences dans lequel on peut s'informer
sur la technologie de l'espace à la
géode une boule d'argent énormes on peut
voir des films en trois dimensions le
moyen de transport le plus rapide à
paris c'est le métro pour le retour
prenons notre temps et faisons non